make your shot that's how you practice  it when that's taken away by Cali 32  years old  13th NBA season they bristled veteran if  he will have inflated mental status he  didn't stay down Yanis 4 3 Dennis  five threes in the third quarter for my  Matthews Janice pent-up thirteen second  half against Utah seems to be the charm  they came close in Salt Lake City  30% three-point shooting yeah he  actually hasn't been shoot the  three-ball  [Applause]  is a promise I was playing you're gonna  have to have both but forcing the action  at the rim Utah's very good defensive  team  [Applause]  and the right down into shooting Annette  it's okay as long as she's in those low  30s  [Music]  shows its appreciation to what they've  seen in this third period Yanis kicks it  out  you just got to be smart  [Music]  in the box